so howdy folks maximum McGee here and
today i'm checking out a little game
called endless legend and help me do
that i'm joined by homer halloo nice to
meet you again last time we met I
believe it was at GGC earlier this year
um before we get to that let's set up
what is in this legend what are we
seeing right now okay so endless legends
is a4x fantasy sorta g game so it's set
in the same universe as a nice base our
previous game you know so it's are you
playing on planets set in this that's
fantasy fiction science fiction universe
right you guys have like a series of
games that all have the prefix of
endless and they all sort of tie
together in some ways they're all very
different games in their own yeah the
first one was science fiction you know
you were like one Empire like conquering
the galaxy and this one you know you
will be on one of these planets and
trying to one of the people display and
strength to survive actually that's very
hostile planet somehow and and the other
one doctor on the endless is a just a
game that we know just love that we just
created to connect these two universes
like to show the link between the two so
I imagine in typical forex strategy what
we're about to do here start settling
our first city doing some research maybe
getting some military units on the field
talk us through what were our exactly so
right now you're playing the vaulters
it's a very classic civilization of our
game most of them I to a pretty a
symmetrical there's some of the only
truth or level science you know but here
you know we play classic civilization
linked to to all the universes like to
they are kind of a spacefaring guys like
a loss on that planet they just want to
escape the planet here what you see is a
we are like a cranial city so the world
you know the it's the training of that
world is not X icon all and with the
heights different heights so depending
on where you place the city you can have
a very good vantage point very good
defensive position you can actually if
you go higher up he'll most likely to
find the trend words which are good for
production done by sea probably better
for food or under the rivers actually
here like we've found pretty nice place
where we can have actually a good
mixture of food science industry dust
be pretty good city to start the game so
now we're going to attack some little
guys nor on us so that world is filled
with like smaller what we call
manufactures that you can that will
attack you if you don't do anything but
if you manage to either negotiate with
them or kill them all go subdue them
yeah they will join your empire so
sometimes willingly something is not by
doing that it's when they do join your
empire they will give your part 1 new
trait that will change the way your
civilization interact with a widow world
Neil science burners there will you you
know better movements on your troops so
then I can actually point of the game
can be extremely interesting and they
also will allow their troops to fight
for you get recruit them it looks like
when we engaged in battle with these
creatures the map sort of changed a
little bit but the I don't think the
actual layout of the map has changed it
all right no no it's exactly the same
loud we would just simplified so it's
easier to read but actually we can't
just fight this battle by the same time
we could go back on our city and manage
it so we could have another fight beside
cannot two fights going on it's one
place one time we didn't want it whether
to have battles that you know would be
another matter was taking place on some
other yeah and they lose time and then
you know I think it takes you away from
the immersion you know because it's
somewhere else so that sense of
community force was very important and
also we put a lot of effort and trying
to have the train at the center of the
strategy right you were talking about
the importance of elevation earlier
and it's even more true obviously for
battles you know so you want to always
have the high ground you want to
especially for your archers or to use
the truck one to your advantage and
depending on how from where you attack
you know that that village you know it
will totally change you know the layout
of the battle but the good thing is you
can always plan ahead ok so now we are
going to attack so we are on the hill as
you can see there's before we attack we
have all of our Eclipse and there's only
one Potter passage I have a lot of
troops I can attack from distance
actually so I will be at your altar on
that heal okay I try to hopefully
completely crush we definitely have the
high ground in the scenario exactly so
that's why the it's always good to plan
ahead so they had a lot of calories
especially not a lot of distances are
going to be good for me yeah i have here
so that should be good yeah right fights
so we SAT like offensive position
so what sort of determines where the
units fan out to on the battle okay so
what happens is the where we meet is the
center of the battle that's the only 2 X
icons that touch each others have been
or why not related on the f3 touching
but that's the middle one iron and and
from there you know that troops will
deploy behind me when I were attacked
with my troops and behind the others now
the only thing they need to have a path
that goes from the original points to
the rest of the match if there is no
path they can't deploy to that areas you
sometimes you can even like cause I'm
like a guy isolated on some other
particles I else you wouldn't you
wouldn't make sense you know it would
you would wonder why he would appear
there wait you can go there that
sometimes we would try to do is to cover
some people in some situation where they
can't deploy the whole army so right now
what we think we deploy our troops we
chose you know a good position the all
the white dots that you see is the moral
of each one of the troops morale is
influenced by the number of units they
have around them so the more they're
surrounded better the stronger they will
be the end of more powerful level be now
they are that is to try to put your
troops together in lucky as a group and
to try to hold the best altitude the
best positions with your troops together
so it's pretty interesting because it
gives you a sense of them having I kind
of military lines with no shortages now
like what we just did we just cast a
spell which is what we can do as you
know the other images images they are
kind of the only real mages of that
world and they are the more that's the
only ones who can't cast spells in
battle or actually also on the adventure
map where they can also nicastri
economical spin so for playing is the
blue art majors who are we fighting
so that's what the rotting plants that's
another one of deflections have been
introduced in with better lately the
guys the warring clans cannot declare
word to anyone even if they wanted go to
it they come they can only provoke you
to do so and decide to I just harass you
enough okay yeah I hanging in there
really good advertising so that's why I
mean they're extremely annoying as
neighbors so the good thing is they can
they're good with commerce you need to
be friends with them to exchange
anything so if you want biosensing on
the marketplace you need to be in good
terms wherever everything you're going
to sell them they're going to take a
shuttle they want you guys talk science
yeah so that if you're getting paying
they're getting paid and even unhappy
with you they just expel you Americans
and that's critical problematic you need
resources to build your armies and
sometimes one of the best way to get
these resistance is through the
marketplace so that leads pretty cool
tricks what they can do also is one of
the new things well site for the better
that's what we call the privateers the
privateers are when you have armies
composed only of bursaries as you can
see which will be crushed okay i was
watching guys on the rifle for slow and
a pretty good units so so pretty happy
with that so in its right away and so
the mercenaries if you if you make
Army's only of some mercenaries you can
tell them to become privateers and
privateers nobody know who is the owner
of this purchase they are just like kind
of they look like random units coming
from the computer from you know these
minor factions but actually they are
being over there being behind the theme
or by someone else you can do like some
proxy war fair play and all like Gary I
and sometimes what we do is especially
not a player it's like you know it's one
guy which send like some the
conspirators between two other guys so
it looks like it's coming from one of
the two so so you have some pretty cool
place I cogic all stuff you can do and
sometimes you could even see situations
where people attack their lies with that
if you
the best friends you know I won't be in
good terms with you and I do all these
tricky things so it's pretty cool
addition to the game that we're that we
added yes sir I know you guys have just
moved from from sort of the alpha phase
into the beta phase in addition to
privateers like what else has changed so
so basically by reaching the the beat up
whether the game is mostly complete we
have certain things that water to add
but the whole gameplay loop is there
there's only what's up basically wet
weather is like but at the roots as you
can see the root system and the whole
commerce system which is linked to the
roads we didn't want to go through
micromanagement of building roads so so
what you do when you create the city you
can create a building which is wrote on
that city and it will connect you city
to the coolest city at least in your
region and by taking the fastest path so
if normally you would have built you
sent by hand that wrote it would have
taken that same path because that's what
makes more sense and later your caravans
will use these roads to to do the covers
and through the real networks it will be
create about all the players you know
you can slowly reach further and further
places so you have like you know better
caravans but someone can try to cut you
know you caravan routes and try the web
I can't land I start laying into your
profits a little bit then you want to
attack that because you want to go back
to your profits so that's the same that
the same on see you know we have
seaports and the seaports will try to
connect to all the ports in the world
look in my a distance so again you will
want to control the kind of things so
also we added some supports we added the
ships right now you can you know and
bark anywhere in the world okay the
marketplace was already there before but
you know we have a lot of things that no
we can do waste bishop with robin
clients roving clans so we know we're
not playing at the working class but if
you were playing as working clans here
you would see all the exchanges from all
the others so you know your little ones
who know who bought what in who for work
so you know what they need wanta
creating for it and you know you know
what you need maybe to to stock up to
sell to any more you can adjust the
market is actually make sure you know
you're the one who profit from that so
it's pretty it's pretty
this inversion you can sell what we
added with the diplomacy diplomacy was
there in very basic form you way more
less or less always at war as you see
this little like purple star and yeah we
call that influence and everything has a
influence cost and in the diplomacy and
the more you get along with someone the
more like negative actions are expensive
in terms of influence and therefore you
know if you want to declare war someone
that you don't want to pay fortune in
terms of influence and influence is used
for the class if it's also used to for
any kind of political actions in your
empire you can invest that support what
we call Empire plans which gives you big
bonus for the next 20 terms so instead
of just like flat-out point 1 i'm even
want to like wear them down a little bit
exactly insults and so it's and
therefore you know you know that someone
is coming for you you know it is not
like wait like a surprise yeah like what
how you do it so it gives also that
sense of very logical there's a
progression it contributes to to make it
believable basically and and everything
that we do in building that game is to
ensure there's nothing that takes you
out of that belief no you want to make
sure that you you you there and and that
different see by understanding what the
others want and how they get their it
helps you to do to contribute to that so
have you guys talked about a release
window movies timing so we announced
that so we were told actually a last
week community that we are coming out we
hope think of my heart you know so when
you go snoring plan either going to plan
by the end of the summer okay which is
also the good trade a good thing but
being independent you know you you aim
at a window you know it and if you happy
with the game you're you do it if you're
not happy you know you're you delay you
know it's not sure you know other than
that so but yeah we definitely hope to
reach the end of sir the thing is also
for us we literally are looking looking
forward to have the game being out
because you know it's another phase of
the life of thinking that starts you
know where we can start you know adding
new content again we can you know it now
on NS pace with like six free DLC
is plus you know an expansion pack and
this kind of stuff that you know we want
to be too gone you know with a life of
the game and also by going alive know we
have quite a lot of players already all
the excess but we'll have a lot more
players also with that and it's also a
new feedback coming in new strategies
coming here and you know so it's all
just good data yeah good data exactly I
would like to thank you so much for sit
down chat with thank you